[Music]
it's la cañada Tanya
Oh Monsieur is over acts a lot in this
job three cyclists team Astana francs
sorry Cara it'll display Selena is our
man
Geico Cano says Ekaterina Mendoza Zika
little kind of Kashi small Nakata what I
can never get caught in the city
mr. icd-10 will show after my 13 with
systemic in Chichibu Japan just two
hours outside Tokyo lies a museum unlike
any other for the past 27 years
Yoshi Co has been the owner of the only
Museum in the entire world dedicated to
human faces found within rocks more than
just being the backbone of a museum the
rocks have long held a special place in
you Chico's family history you knew that
if Cara has not there cheers your mother
so where are these a signal to talk kata
northwestern sorry they haven't skiied
nap hundred American you took the hot
box
- no sister no I'm not gonna take her
long to finish mine I'm not actually a
souvenir Masamune Shirow
Anoka still rockin on the show day then
boo de da de da k Demoiselle Cobra
and the collection is constantly
expanding Yoshi Co routinely goes out to
the local river searching for new rocks
for the collection just as her father
had
who knows you are only on Tony D meeting
the other couples don't know our
Shelton's Corrales man Nova Scotia -
Conda Hoonah accosted a little on today
the immensity of its Karen Naniwa
Methodist armory Melbourne an honorary
technique to go for long enough director
he's under total Mozilla so haha I'm not
even what play in this game
none of us are honestly a little
together enough okay to Yoshika hi yama
goes to great lengths to collect new
rocks but she's not the only one
people all around the world send in new
rocks the dedicated few even make the
trek all the way to rural Japan to see
these one-of-a-kind rocks for themselves
[Music]
no coconut would photobooks it pretty
much over there is amazing yes another
look at our satellite I said Alaska demo
which is around you that is taking a
terracotta ma night don't worry Mouse
man not a vehicle on its you know
Memorial weekend 3 they're not Glasgow
that kiss a cow a pig it is almost
enough
[Music]
strong Museum in Rochester New York is
also known as the National Museum of
play more than 1/2 million objects are
here
my name is Chris bench I'm vice
president for collections at the Museum
and its chief curator our collections
are divided by category and here are
some of the people who are responsible
for them in our collection we have
around 10,000 board games and it
parallels essentially American history
since the Revolution when you think in
terms of games they all tend to
represent the areas in which they were
created it's a different way of getting
into the mindset of people who lived a
hundred years ago in this collection we
have more than 15,000 dolls and expands
from the 18th century to present day
dolls are special because of the way
that we connect with them we project
ourselves our hobbies or interests our
values towards others when we look at
the history of dolls and how we played
with them it shows that we connect to
people from the past and ways that we
might not have expected we have over 250
arcade machines and over 100 pinball
machines in the collection pinball is
real you can feel the way the game plays
you can feel the way the game moves and
you're dead you're playing it's just in
my nature to keep his machines going
they were made the last five years in a
commercial environment and the fact that
we have games that are 30 40 50 60 years
old is amazing to me
so I'm curator
[Music]
this collection has more than 70,000
objects toys always reflect what's going
on in the world around them when it's
economic boom times construction toys
are big when the US is at war we see all
sorts of military and war toys the toy
collection is a wonderful example of how
times have changed and people have
changed over the years changed over the
years can we understand how we've
developed as people and how we've played
over the centuries
[Music]
in Guanajuato Mexico there is a museum
filled entirely with mummies
[Music]
mi nombre es Paloma rope s like a yo-yo
le directeur adele museo de las mamiya's
de guanajuato el museo de las Diez de
guanajuato es un presentó sagrado kxe
hay una collection pneumonias Naturalis
with 117 bodies in total the museum has
the largest collection of natural
mummies in the world the mummies are the
well-preserved remains of people who
died during a cholera outbreak in Mexico
in the 1800s the museum is a haunting
and eerie experience for visitors an
opportunity to stare death in the face
Vienna Boys Kara's experiencia intima sa
encuentro Mistico con la muerte que
propecia la relación enter no a la
intención su propia vida y Ascencio de
la misma es importante que las personas
no tengan miedo la muerte yell contrary
oh no bear mo phenomena natural como una
transición inevitable des resistencia
porque finalmente chemin encontrar
Konoha
[Music]
some of the greatest works of art are
just beneath the waves standing in just
25 feet of water off the coast of Cancun
Mexico the Moose AO sub Aquatica at the
arte is both a monument to human
creativity and the natural beauty of the
Caribbean reef ecosystem the museum is a
vast collection of underwater galleries
with over 500 sculptures many focused on
themes of human interaction and impact
on the environment the Marine Park where
the museum is located is one of the most
visited stretches of water in the world
with nearly 800,000 visitors each year
immense pressure is placed on the native
reef ecosystem that's why every
sculpture is made from cement suitable
for the growth of coral seaweed and
algae the many holes in the sculptures
make perfect homes for marine wildlife
to colonize and feed off the coral the
hope is that as nature continues to
colonize these statues they will
transform into massive reefs
unrecognizable for what they once were
and it's also attractive to humans it
has become one of the most popular dive
locations in the area hopefully
signaling a more prosperous relationship
between man and nature
[Music]
in spring-green Wisconsin there is a
house on Iraq but it is so much more
than that inside it is home to many
bizarre and incredible collections
there's a room of self playing
instruments an infinity room a giant
squid attacking a whale and some
nightmare-inducing dolls it seems like a
really strange Museum and that's because
no it appears to be Museum because it is
housing antiques it's housing all kinds
of memorabilia and things from a
different era it's more of a place to
just enjoy so what is house on the rock
the house on the rock to me is a magical
complex it's an all-around sensory
explosion it was made by Alex Jordan who
was an architect not at all not at all
he is not a trained man he's just a man
of great vision maybe not an architect
but an evident hoarder Alex Jordan with
the help of his friends built the house
on the rock in the 40's and opened it to
the public in the 60s his collections of
antiques and junk new items and old real
and quite obviously fake have no central
theme or apparent reason for being there
and maybe that's part of its charm there
are some pretty incredible things
including a huge unraidable carousel 269
different animals not one of them is a
horse really yes the horses adorn the
walls of course they do you know every
time you turn the corner here it's a
different thing and it's a different Wow
and you don't know what to expect one
man's trash is another man's roadside
tourist attraction
[Music]
you
[Music]
it's very different from every other
collection in the world and if you're a
collector at heart you can't really stop
my name is Jeff 2-0
I'm the curator and owner of the
Icelandic phallological Museum
my father was given a right bull penis
epistle back in 1974 as a joke and
that's all most part the idea you know
to start collecting these things all the
lights are made from scrotum skins right
now we have 285 different specimens it's
still growing the collection we get
maybe three to five every year the most
fascinating things is the diversity
there are huge differences in size
shapes a color etc here is the the
biggest specimens we have it's a sperm
whale it's about 70 kilos maybe 150
pounds and here is one of my favorites
the world was one the hardest to get was
the human one no question about that it
was 95 when he died so the specimen is a
bit Franky
it's what it does to people your
everything shrinks but we're hopeful
we'll get a better example so people say
you know they are just happy because
they realize that there's nothing new
here there's no pornography was just you
know education and fun
[Music]
you
[Music]